[Musique]
et nous a rejoint seconde invitée
politique c'est brice hortefeux bonjour
ici merci beaucoup d'être avec nous
député européen membre des républicains
pascal jalabert du groupe ebra qui est
toujours à mes côtés brice hortefeux est
ce que les républicains peuvent parler
de victoire bien sûr on est préoccupé
par par soi même c'est humain mais enfin
d'abord ce scrutin et nous encourage à
formuler plusieurs observations et
surtout attirer un certain nombre de
leçons
ça a été dit et répété à juste titre
mais la très faible participation est un
sujet majeur c'est pas simplement lié
aux cocos vite c'est pas simplement les
aux conditions d'organisation des votes
c'est pas simplement lié au fait que
seulement 15% la réalité des communes
étaient concernées c'est un problème et
les plus grandes villes qui
s'abstiennent et c'est un problème qui
s'inscrit dans la durée
ça signifie qu'il y a certainement des
questions à la fois de fond et de forme
les questions de forme c'est peut-être
faut-il faire évoluer la manière de
voter aujourd'hui tout se fait de
manière sûre le téléphone est ainsi tué
bas peut-être qu'il faut faire évoluer
le système de vote sur internet
peut-être où il ya deux est favorable va
en tout cas je suis favorable à ce qu'il
y ait une participation civique qui soit
plus forte parce que ça confère
davantage de légitimité aujourd'hui la
plupart des maires sont élus en fait
avec 20 % du corps électoral s'il ya un
problème de légitimité d'incarnation
brard j'y suis pas favorable parce que
par tempérament je suis pour la liberté
dont je suis le vote obligatoire ça veut
dire c'est encore punitif donc on a déjà
l'écologie qui est totalement punitive
puisque c'est des interdits des
licenciements par les voilà et puis donc
je suis pour la liberté mais il faut
qu'ils aient un système sur le sueur
sur la forme qu'ils soient sans doute
plus ou et puis surtout il ya une vraie
question de fond juste moi je suis un
peu déçu qu'on n'en parle pas c'est que
la démocratie ne se nourrit de la
confrontation des idées de la
confrontation entre des majorités des
oppositions et la réussite des mails
mâcon en 2017 qui je pense n'était qu'un
leurre c'est précisément d'essayer de
gommer tous les clivages et donc il faut
qu'ils aient des clivages il faut qu'il
y ait débat c'est de la confrontation
que naît le progrès que vous qu'avancent
les idées et donc à vouloir tout
aseptiser m'a finalement dit à quoi ça
sert on n'est ni écoutés dit compris
alors justement vous parlez
confrontation est ce qu'une nouvelle
confrontation n'est pas en train de
s'installer avec d'un côté l'écologie
qui est un thème central ce qui dit il
faut faire plus
il faut au moins deux voitures ils font
moins de il faut une carbonique sites
industriels
et puis de l'autre côté d'autres qui
lisent bien on peut pas faire la
transition aussi vite ce qui repeignent
fracture à la fois territoriale et et
sociologique
oui je pense que vous avez raison mais
parle moi je réponds quand même à la
première question c'est sur les
républicains je dis juste simplement
j'allais revenir mais je sais pour ça je
ne sais pas mais je vais essayer de
répondre dans l'ordre est bon le
concerne ma famille l'est républicain
brrr il y à une réalité qui est une
réalité personne ne peut contester c'est
que nous sommes aujourd'hui la première
force des territoires nous sommes
d'ailleurs la première force au sénat
nous sommes la première force
d'opposition à l'assemblée mais nous
sommes encore sans doute la première
force militante mais nous sommes la
première force des territoires est
plutôt d'ailleurs dans les villes
moyennes que dans les grandes villes
encore que mais c'est cette réalité
on parle beaucoup du de perpignan mais
ça ne gâche sein fait que cacher la
forêt puis ce qui aurait été une
rassemblement national des dizaines de
vies ils ont une dizaine de villes vont
très bien passée de 56 % des devils rue
l'une des formations issues du premier
tour c'est ça ce matin c'est combien je
ne sais pas
le détail mais c'est ce qui est confirmé
si vous voulez c'est que on est là les
républicains sont aujourd'hui la
première force des territoires est ce
que ça veut dire que pour autant tout et
rêver non il ya un troisième leçon de ce
scrutin c'est le désastre du pouvoir en
place
ça a été dit j'ai juste titre d'ailleurs
mais il y à cette réalité c'est que
jamais jamais depuis le début de la vème
république le parti du président on
obtient un aussi faible résultat est à
l'occasion d'un scrutin municipal
j'écoutais hier comme vous certainement
le responsable du parti présidentiel et
les avancées le fait qu'ils auraient
sans doute 200 mères qui serait dès
qu'ils seraient dans marche dans du
parti présidentiel doivent écouter et
vous rendez compte il ya 36000 communes
et puis la plupart c'est des gens qui
étaient déjà là il ya une conquête c'est
leur succès sont ceux qui est parce
qu'ils étaient là avant c'était vous cet
échec de jeu
je lui explique parce que vous savez
l'accumulation des chèques abouti que
très rarement un grand succès vous avez
eu un échec social avec la cad gestion
catastrophique des gilet jaune qui
s'éternise et faujour jamais vu cela
vrai dire dans la durée vous avez un
échec sanitaire parce que évidemment on
avait tous les soirs les commentaires
d'une profession sur le monde nous
expliquons tout allait très bien que les
autres ça allait très mal mais la
réalité que vous il ya une enquête qui
était assez intéressante qui a été
publié sur les 32 pays de l'union
européenne mais y compris des petits
territoires le liechtenstein vous savez
il ya trente deux pays on est classée
26e en matière de gestion de la crise
sanitaire
26e sur 32 vous rendez compte on a eu
cinq à six fois plus de deux morts en
proportion que la plupart de nos voisins
c'est à cet échec sanitaire
spectaculaire
si c'est nous qui disons peut-être qu'on
peut dire oui sont dans l'opposition non
c'est l'ancien leproux ancien directeur
général de la santé et qui lui-même à
dénoncer la médiocrité de la gestion la
craie et puis vous avez troisième
élément de cette paire cette perspective
de 10
culte et économique et qui qui
s'additionnent et que les français
anticipe parfaitement savez on sait que
on a un recul de notre richesse de 12%
du ca 12 % du pib recule on sait qu'on
va avoir la fin de l'année 12 % de
chômeurs on sait qu'on va avoir une des
dettes les plus impressionnants du monde
occidental donc échec sanitaire échec
social échec économique et financier à
venir c'est assez logique que le pouvoir
soit sanctionné mais il a été sanctionné
coûte c'est un échec national c'est un
échec le cas c'est de passer l'orage moi
moi écouter vous savez quand on veut tu
sais on vote pas pour le défendre des
oiseaux à l'échelon local et puis sur un
autre sujet au niveau national non c'est
un coin un bulletin de vote ça toujours
une signification bien sûr locales et
bien sûr aussi nationale
donc c'est un échec sans précédent il
n'ya historique pour le pouvoir en place
voilà cette réalité alors vous dites les
républicains sur la première phase dans
les territoires vous avez quand même du
mal à parler de victoire et pour cause
on va parler de marseille marseille qui
a de fortes chances de basculer à gauche
après 25 ans de jean-claude gaudin est
ce que pour vous marseille est encore
gagnable ce matin je n'en sais rien
j'imagine qu'il doit y avoir des
discussions puisque marseille celui qui
ne gagne ne gagnera que par des
alliances y en a aucun qui peut gagner
tout seul donc il faudra passer des
alliances qu'est ce que ces avis
réservés moi je me méfie de
l'utilisation de ce mot parce que ça
peut laisser entendre discussions
d'arrière boutique le couloir de tout ça
c'est pas ça c est cette semaine à
kinshasa le troisième tour passé un
accord avec samia ghali ça vous choque
ou pas vous
ça veut dire qu'ils se sont mis d'accord
sur un projet commun s'ils sont mis
d'accord sur un projet commun avec ce
projet commun est majoritaire en nombre
d'élus c'est assez logique est que
la victoire revienne finale à martin la
salle mais je n'en sais rien mais en
tout cas à marseille ce que je sais moi
je suis pas marseillais je suis un
provincial je suis le hand over mais
j'ai regardé les yeux écarquillés
c'est cette division de la droite
marseillaise c'est absolument vous savez
division vous savez l'union c'est pas la
garantie absolue du succès mais c'est
souvent une des conditions voilà on en a
la démonstration pour revenir à la
question vous est posée sur l'écologie
aujourd'hui ce sont vos principaux
adversaires
enfin on va voir d'abord comment ils
vont être confrontés à la réalité moi je
vous dis je suis pas particulièrement
rassuré quand j'entends les grands
principes deviendra pgt provincial moi
je suis ou lui
j'ai comme beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
français de me déplacer bon quand on
nous dit il faut pas d'avion ensuite il
faut mais attention faut pas de tgv non
plus hein
attention s'il faut pas surtout parce
que le lait versé pas de pad avions pas
de tgv et qu'on nous explique que
maintenant sur autoroute il va falloir
rouler à 110 km/heure et y aura
naturellement d'ici deux ans un génie
des carpates qui nous expliquera qu'il
faut rouler à 90 sur les autoroutes 20
bas et incitent huit mois j'ai pas envie
par ces particules est doublé par les
hérissons je vois donc je suis honnête
je vous ai dit un peu inquiet mais
maintenant il faut qu'ils soient
confrontés à la réalité de l'exercice
loire c'est pas simplement des postures
c'est pas simplement des formules c'est
pas simplement des slogans c'est pas
simplement des promenades comme la jeune
fille
en bateaux ici ou là et c'est une
gestion du quotidien une gestion
municipale on verra comment il gère
particulièrement par exemple la
circulation ou la protection ça tout est
noir capacité à gérer des villes écouter
les électeurs c'est dans une démocratie
il faut s'incliner devant les électeurs
par définition les lecteurs à raison
donc les électeurs ont choisi ils ont
choisi dans un certain nombre d'endroits
et des élus écologistes
écoutez maintenant ils sont élus qui
gouverne et puis on observera comment il
règle les problèmes précisé mende les
problèmes sociaux alléchant de leur
commune les problèmes d'éducation
allègement des compétences communales
comment ils règlent les questions
financières et budgétaires qui vont être
extrêmement dix ans des rendez vous
extrêmement difficiles à venir avec la
crise du que nous avons que nous avons
vécue et que nous vivons encore donc il
y aura tout cela et on jugera sur pièces
mais vous savez il ya quelques années
c'était pas les écrits c'était le front
national il avait gagné toulon et on a
eu des bas il faut qu'il faut qui montre
comment il gère une grande ville ils
nous ont montré il ça a été une
catastrophe est virtuellement il ya eu
alternance la fois d'après on vient
observons ce que comment font les verts
quand ils sont à la tête de villes
importantes à l'est puisque vous parlez
du front national un mot sur perpignan
en 2014 jean marc pujol avait battu
louis aliot hier celle inverse
louis aliot a battu jean marc pujol le
candidat des républicains ce que marine
le pen a raison de dire que le front
républicain vit ses derniers moments
marie le pen j'ai intéressée qu'elle
intervienne sur perpignan puisqu'elle
s'est pas déplacé à perpignan qu'il n'y
avait pas de d'étiquettes du
rassemblement national à perpignan
c'était une bonne campagne mon avis
assez localiser et c'est surtout là qui
ne doit pas cacher la forêt le front
national avait une dizaine de villes
mais à partir du moment où on est battus
ce peut être un succès vous avez raison
je peux pas malade su vous démentir
enfin c'est cette réalité c'est que le
lia le fonds national est aujourd'hui
dans l'impuissance territoriales voilà
la vella succès de pertinentes ne peut
pas masquer cette réalité partout et il
avait présenté en moins de disques la
dernière fois tiers qui est moins de
potentiel humain et donc ils sont
aujourd'hui dans la situation actuelle
il était en 2014 une dizaine de villes
alors jean françois copé et d'autres ont
dit la droite a encore tout à faire dans
les deux années à venir
vous êtes d'accord avec ça et qu'est ce
qu'il faut faire oui nous partons pas de
rien heureusement nous sommes la
première force militante sans doute je
le disais pour première force au sénat
première force d'opposition à
l'assemblée et première force régionale
première force aussi à l'échelon
départemental
donc nous avons un socle est un socle
fort important et qui nous permet
certainement de rebondir c'est la
première chose deuxièmement il faut que
l'on incarne un courant on s'appelle on
peut pas gagner des élections si elles
m'ont donné on n'est pas porteur d'un
courant donc il faut qui est
l'incarnation d'une ligne et qui est une
ligne qui doit être une mine responsable
crédible
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la vie publique
s'articule autour des partis de
gouvernement et des partis
protestataires entre guillemets mais
c'est encore sur la sauce aux clients
nous devons être
partis de gouvernement c'est à dire être
capable de gérer sans tomber dans les
schémas les caricaturer un situé devant
et puis il faut qu'il y ait une
incarnation le moment venu bien sûr
aussi si vous avez une force territoria
mi temps 7 8 6 où vous incarnez un
courant d'opinion et si vous avez
quelqu'un pour un quart des secours en
et bien je pense qu'on en a fait
l'essentiel du chemin mais aujourd'hui
mais l'ensemble encore pas là vous avez
on a perdu en 2010 est de manière
absolument incroyable l'actualité nous
rappelle mais enfin on a eu un débat
présidentiel qui était totalement
escamoté et donc sans doute un résultat
qui a été faussée donc c'est normal
qu'ils étaient closes ayant été
traumatisés parce que pour la première
fois depuis le début de sa créature
blick le candidat que nous soutenions
n'est pas arrivé à ce être finalistes
donc c'est un choc
extraordinairement durs et violents dans
une démocratie et donc il faut se
prépare à ça mais ça n'enlève pas la
question de fond on ne peut gagner on ne
peut rebondir
ceva là pour nous comme pour tous les
autres que si on est utile si on est
inutile à la vie de notre pays on est
balayé c'est à nous de montrer que l'on
est utile à la vie démocratique en étant
ce que j'appelle moi aujourd'hui une
opposition positive c'est-à-dire est
cette utilité vous pourriez l'a montré
dans le prochain gouvernement est ce que
c'est un remaniement c'est bien qu'ils
aient dlr qui rentre au gouvernement pas
besoin je n'y crois pas de bon ça a été
fait et refait en 2010 est de toute
manière des débauchés tel ou tel edouard
philippe c'est une victoire de la droite
au havre il est maire il était maire élu
sous l'étiquette ump il a défié quitter
sa famille politique pour voguer vers
matignon c'est un choix personnel
c'est pas moins de personnes comme ça
que je conçois la vie publique mais mais
en tout cas c'est un choix personnel
qu'il a fait mais enfin au havre par en
venir je serai
habitant du havre vous aviez le choix
entre edward philippe et le candidat
communiste soutenu par la france
insoumise franchement action qui seriez
vous avec les convictions qui sont les
miennes je me vois mal soutenir je vais
certainement très sympathique députés le
coq m'enfin a priori plus spontanément
je suis prêt à porter après apporter mon
soutien et merci beaucoup merci ça me
fait d'avoir été avec nous ce matin